Es agradable y claro que Biden haya sido elegido.
oportunidad política mucho más amplia
resultó ser un gran éxito de taquilla al gen resultado
velar al presidente o lo que, como era de esperar,
proclama la película pandémica y hulk y
completar el programa de desayuno teva y
con lo cual guardo la sorpresa del equipo cerebral
la súper acción de la crisis económica y otras
de máster previo que luego imparte
reformar el sistema de inmigración
particularmente de América Latina y
Centroamérica especialmente se los
estados unificados asi que no a los dos de lo que
el que se la rompe al final
ampliamos edificios que no lo son y
Espero que eso pueda resultar
es una reforma y es una situación muy
impuesto positivo al smog primero cebos ahora
Echa un vistazo a la Casa Blanca
la camara de diputados y el senado o lo que sea
sea ​​solo por un voto
son 50 para el senador demócrata a los 50
Republicano y el presidente del Senado.
arresto en habitación
esta mina democratizada y luego se va a usar
en la votación es necesario dar la
victoria en la propuesta del puesto de póquer
de tablones claramente tengo porquería
ademas eso va a cambiar dale el impulso
señuelos positivos biden mismo vs nador
d'Este cuando tienes 30 y un
período suave y amplio y en el que con prima
Reflexiono sobre cómo funciona el Senado
creo alianzas toda la reputacion
hablar con todos los senadores
mismos demócratas del sur que fueron
segregacionista abiertamente racista y
Stoller de una excelente experiencia.
contacto si excelente reputacion
mou es positivo para tra vaar con perdido
Los republicanos son señales de que
una esperanza que pregunta a cual el cras
Las almas oscuras prometen, respondió.
diciendo que yo era presidente para todos
American tiene sí que ayat al partido.
Vemos un período de calma en el país.
Aún no se ha resuelto el problema.
importante y avanzar en retribuir a
país en nivel de importancia
luz internacional con la pandemia y
para resolver la crisis económica